what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so as you guys know I don't do fan
theory videos very often I usually like
to keep facts keep things pretty
straightforward but sometimes I have a
theory that's so amazing that I have to
tell you guys about it all right I
posted this to Reddit and it's got five
up votes which I'm proud of I'm proud of
those five up votes but it has five up
votes as of right now which I'm very
satisfied with and um I and I want to
run this theory by you guys all right I
want to know what you guys think about
this all right this is the theory on
what Nick Fury said to Thor and why he
can't lift his hammer so I've been
thinking about this for quite some time
and I think that our discussion on the
untold origin Emil near holds the answer
to what it was a Nick Fury set so for
those of you guys who didn't see that
video which you'll find down in the
description basically Jason Aaron came
back and added to the history of Thor's
hammer he essentially said that at one
point Odin had fought off trolls who
were trying to invade the land of the
drawers because the dwarves are so good
at crafting stuff and you know Odin
needed their crafting ability so in
thanks for his efforts
the dwarves gave Odin a piece of guru
metal which is supposedly the most
durable metal in the Marvel Universe the
only exception to that is true
adamantium which is what was bonded to
Wolverine's skeleton now having said
that Odin didn't consider much of this
earu metal but there was a giant cosmic
storm that was moving towards Asgard it
was wiping out you know galaxies and
solar systems and so on and it was
moving towards Asgard and it threatened
to wipe out as God now the way Jason
Aaron wrote this this store was the
storm was angry was it was basically
sent him is what he was saying he was a
sentient storm that was wiping out all
life and you know Odin used the power of
the odinforce to confine the storm
within this chunk of guru metal because
uber metal has magical properties and it
blends well with magic and so it just
worked
whatever anyway he takes this chunk of
guru metal with the storm confined
inside to the dwarves and says forge
this into a weapon that I can use
because it'll be beastly it'll be
insanely powerful because it's infused
with the power of this cosmic storm so
the dwarves start forging the
metal into a hammer which they give to
Odin and when Odin tries to wield it he
can't because the hammer seems to have a
will of its own and so in response Auden
puts an enchantment on the hammer that
says no one can wield this all right no
one can lift this hammer now it sits in
the armory it stays there for however
long and then eventually Odin has Thor
now as a child
Thor was curious about the hammer and
let's say maybe he formed a kinship with
it maybe he didn't whatever the reason
as Thor grew into adulthood
he was viewed as being a worthy
successor to you know the throne of
Asgard he was considered an honourable
son by Odin and let's say that they go
into the armory whatever you know Odin
says pick your poison to grab any weapon
you want to and Thor says I want the
hammer and Odin says no one can lift the
hammer before says I want it anyway and
so Odin removes the enchantment it says
fine if you can lift it you can use it
and so Thor was able to lift the hammer
for whatever reason all right maybe the
hammer chose him whatever the case may
be but Odin's son was able to use the
hammer and carry it around and so onand
modify the original and champion that
said nobody can wield this hammer and
instead replaced it with whosoever holds
this hammer if he be worthy shall
possess the power of Thor yadda yadda
yadda so that's why Odin's son was able
to wield his hammer for so long now
let's also assume that Odin's son did
not know the hammer was sentient instead
he just assumed for whatever reason he
can lift it and so once he picked it up
he became the Thor that we all know and
love and so on and so forth of decades
past whatever Avengers so on and so
forth
eventually original sin happens now
original sin established that Nick Fury
was not just the director of shield he
was not just the executive director that
he was the man on the wall he was the
one protecting the planet Earth from all
types of threats inside the earth beyond
the earth and space in the universe and
other dimensions other realms but he had
access to all kinds of technology to
knowledge on a wide array of different
things now let's assume that in his
travels he had basically learned about
the original enchantment that Odin put
on the hammer that nobody could wield it
and that Odin had modified the
enchantment to say only though
those who were worthy could lift the
hammer now let's say during original sin
that during the battle between Odin Sun
and Nick Fury Nick Fury did not whisper
anything to Odin son Nick Fury spoke to
the hammer and removed the enchantment
so there was no longer an enchantment
binding the hammer to Thor but there was
also no longer an enchantment saying no
one could wield it instead the hammer
was able to operate of its own free will
and chose not to let Odin son lift it
this would explain why neither Odin son
nor Odin could lift the hammer after
original sin now if that theory is true
the question becomes why can Jane Foster
lifted but no one else can
well the most logical argument here is
that the hammer chose Jane Foster it
chose her to be the one that can wield
it well why did it choose her who knows
I have no clue that's that's I'm a lost
ball on high weeds when it comes to
trying to find the answer to that
question but that is my theory that Nick
Fury removed the enchantment from the
hammer and gave the hammer its ability
to operate of its own accord and so the
hammer is currently sentient it can do
what it wants to and it's just allowing
Jane Foster to use it at the moment
this would also explain why it is that
ever since Jane Foster has been holding
the hammer she's felt like the hammer
was alive but in any event let me know
what you guys think about this theory
I'm kind of curious post a comment down
below and if you guys are new here to
the robb core make sure you guys hit
that sub button become part of the Rob
port and yeah but you guys drop a like -
I love seeing likes and I will catch you
all later peace
[Music]